tenha certeza que todos aqui que
chegamos a ouvir portugal é uma grande
nação marítima ancorada ao produtor de
cobre - e agora passadas mas nós não
somos um povo marítimo
nós somos um povo feliz maioritariamente
junto à costa
acho que só sombra do mar quando a solo
vamos à praia ou estão famosos fazendo
sexo
além disso não acha que há algo
incoerente nesta função de grande nação
marítima
- eu estou constantemente ouvir que
somos pequenos que são os pobres e que
somos prefere começar por justificar
estes pequenos e grandes pés de portugal
iniciou com uma pequena missão de
geografia muito pequena
portugal tem um milhão e 700 mil
quilômetros quadrados do território
natureza marítimo mas os mais claros são
o nosso território 19 vezes mais magra
do que terra para ver melhor esta
dimensão é o equivalente a 40% de toda a
união europeia
cabe no nosso mar todos os países
incluindo a gigante online frança cabeça
dentro do nacional e já agora e a título
de curiosidade e com brincadeira
a montanha mais alta de portugal não é o
pico e também não é serra da estrela
como alguns poderiam já estar a pensar
em corrigir o mundo submarino com 5 mil
metros de altura
é mais ou menos o dobro da altura do
pico fica 200 quilômetros sagas apenas
uma curiosidade se a pessoa tem
curiosidade hoje em dia essas
curiosidades em algumas coisas sobre o
mar
você tem que ser muito sincero convosco
eu nunca quis saber do mar
eu só lembrava eu precisava viver 15
minutos do mar vive em lisboa só me
lembrava do mar em agosto era conectar
os meus pais do festival garfo mais
tarde travis era o mar pra mim era um
sítio onde eu podia nuclear
sabia que tínhamos de buscar e pensava
que tinha 10 de um cursor nos levava
para os nossos arquipélagos o mar era
ouvida praia enquanto vemos o que mudou
muito honra estar aqui convosco e ia
falar sobre o macaco
quando eu fui tirar um mestrado em
estratégia só por si não dava
conhecimento sobre o mar verde a um
professor tudo disse
nós temos uma das maiores zonas
econômicas exclusivas da europa ea 11ª
melhorar e marítimas do mundo porque
nunca ninguém falou sobre isso porque
nunca ninguém me disse eu vou ter de ser
mais e fui windows em outras
investigações que fiz
encontrei o livro da quarta classe a
título de exemplo este livro fala
território cultural descobrimentos e
claro a nossa costa praias e pesca
eu descobri que nunca foi ensinado olha
pro mar
curiosa - as crianças de hoje
sabendo do mar como eu sabia da minha
quarta 4 o melhor sabe mais sobre
dinossauros espécies marinhas exclusiva
perguntar por que eu não sei mas a cbf
não terminou
além de todo o território e que vimos
atrás
portugal assim como outros países
costeiros tv pode estender a chamada
extensão da plataforma continental
então ficará com os direitos sobre o
solo e subsolo marinhos de 4 milhões de
quilômetros quadrados será o equivalente
a 89% toda a união europeia
cabem dentro do nosso mar quase todos os
países da união européia é gigante
portanto já vimos que pequenos nós somos
muito pelo contrário e pobres
já vamos falar sobre isso ultimamente
temos ouvido falar muito de um ingresso
chegar ao mar e o problema da grécia mas
nós vamos lançar ao mar para ir além mar
para conquistar novos territórios
não nós não vamos gastar ao mar nós
dizemos sim reinventar a forma como
olhamos promar e conquistar sim mas ao
nível do conhecimento da exploração e da
conservação do nosso espaço marítimo até
porque agora não é olhar para o mar como
auto estrada e sim como parceiro
econômico sustentável
vai ser um estímulo de uma grana só
marítima
o embarque está em portugal temos um
barco para cada 130 militares
a noruega tem um paraquedas e é pelos
rios que omar caneta e terra para termos
idéia desse traço
basta olhar os prós rio tejo em lisboa
em portugal também somos o maior
consumidor do país que toda a europa e
estamos no top 3 mundial conseguimos
cada um nós em média por ano 57 quilos
de paz 23 57 23 portanto cerca de 60%
buscar abrigos compensar este facto com
a cultura mas ainda não fazemos preocupa
exclusivamente à da cultura são de 11
mil toneladas
os nossos espanhóis produzir cerca de
400 mil toneladas
se quiserem a república checa é um país
sem acesso ao mar por dos 30 mil
toneladas
eu vou curtir não tem mar e produzir
três vezes mais do que nós
gostaria de fazer uma chamada de atenção
à emergência no investimento deste setor
tanto pro futuro da economia portuguesa
como pro futuro da humanidade
nós não podemos continuar a depender de
captura selvagem ocupa se um dia vai
acabar nem podemos continuar a depender
da proteína provimentos animais testes
temos também aqui uma enorme
oportunidade de equilibrar essa balança
comercial e subir estes números a
contribuição da economia do mar para o
pib a média europeia são assim
existem casos extremos como a noruega
produzir em 2010 excluindo brasil
petróleo
depois temos portugal entre 2 e maio é
3%
não há nada que inspira na nossa
economia para o mar que temos estes
números poderiam ser de um país qualquer
montanhoso do interior
mas como já vimos não é isso que
acontece
eu penso que não seja absurdo e não é
absurdo pensar que se os outros
conseguem retirar a riqueza do mar
nós também conseguimos porque não é
claro com a seguinte nós temos que tirar
muito mar
agora temos que pensar que a superfície
para a profundidade do curto para o
longo prazo nós temos desde construção
naval é via tecnologia marinha é a
produção de algas os portes que cada vez
temos que ser mais de vida a nossa
centralidade à energia eólica nos dias
correntes energia das ondas energia
solar tudo no mar
temos um gás natural
temos as pescas que apesar ter sido
negligenciadas no passado com os fundos
porém comentários não podem ser
esquecidas
o transporte marítimo é a cultura
afinal o mara não é só uma auto estrada
os cursos nas traseiras do aimará
discurso que hoje e no futuro poderemos
salvar a aimar e vamos lavar a alma
isto é um sonho já está a acontecer
ainda há pouco tempo surgiram 30 novas
empresas ligadas ao mar em portugal
empresas que fazem a proteção macroalgas
para uso de farmacêutica e cosmética
agroalimentar para a nossa alimentação o
primeiro linguado criado em viveiro foi
feita em portugal fruto de uma tese de
doutoramento e vou iniciar já em 2017
também projetos para início de obra e
que nos guia das ondas
apoiados pelos chamados depois 20 euros
vai para a economia do mar a o os
minérios com os minérios chamado é o
dourado dos oceanos
apesar deste mapa não estar como
totalmente
completo já existe um estranho trabalho
foi tanto nas cidades portuguesas
compreendia cidade de taiz no que se
refere ao conhecimento dos recursos
marinhos é por causa deles nós sabemos
que temos chumbo níquel cobalto ouro
prata entre muitos outros e externas
raras todos nós neste momento não tenho
aqui ficou e nós temos terras raras
negócio e por que a tecnologia nos
smartphones computadores tecnologia
laser turbinas eólicas carros elétricos
todos usam terras raras e nós temos aqui
a nossa cota é nosso é de portugal mas
toda a gente realmente pergunta não
estava eu acho que eu tenho que salvar
um submarino com 1.600 quilômetros
quadrados pode sair por r 300 milhões de
euros
nós temos cerca de 200 de deus coalhadas
que é o nosso sonho nosso mas não pensem
que estamos interessados no nosso cursos
se chegou a portugal em média dois
navios estrangeiros por mês para receber
o que nós temos e ku kyo nós vamos ficar
aqui quero dizer que as fronteiras ficam
cada vez mais diluídas a dívida que os
interesses dos cursos aumentam e nós
temos de estar preparados para assegurar
principalmente a nível do conhecimento
portanto já vimos que pobres também não
somos podemos nos elix mas os cursos
estão cá esse é o nosso também dizem que
somos preferes mas eu acho que somos a
porta da europa em vez de nos
lamentarmos da nossa geografia tudo
devemos aproveitar esta centralidade
atlântica esta localização privilegiada
navegam 85 do comércio europeu faz por
via marítima é melhor passar aqui aporta
navegou qualquer altura 60 mil navios
pelo mundo todo todos auxiliam na
manutenção e para chegar em portugal nem
precisa desviar muito
portugal está no centro das principais
rotas mundiais como se pode ver além de
todo o apoio que nós poderíamos dar ao
nível da distribuição de energia para
obra europe por duch entre muitas outras
vantagens dessa central idades durante
também fazer uma soberania de serviço
entre os países do atlântico norte com
os países do atlântico sul bem como uma
ponte privilegiada com os países da cplp
hoje portugal é um país central no mundo
global e dentro de algumas dezenas de
anos fará parte central da cidade
estratégica de vários continentes
américa a eurásia as três américas e
ásia
o atlântico central será o futuro da
economia mundial
mas atenção com toda esta dimensão com
toda esta riqueza e com toda esta
central idade de creche na cidade de
segurança
nós temos garantir a segurança tanto do
nosso quintal seja a económica alimentar
ambiental
todos nós sabemos que não existe
desenvolvimento sem segurança nessa
existem terra
não garantimos numa 95% das comunicações
que nós fazer a voz o dado foi buscar no
fundo do mar em alguns continentes
nós em portugal temos ligações de lisboa
fechou e sesimbra
basta haver um ataque terrorista um
simples deve largar agora no sítio
errado nós ficarmos e comunicações
ou então acontecer como aconteceu em
taiwan onde um tremor de terra
danificaram seus carros ficaram sem
comunicações durante 49 dias
agora imagine nós ficarão sem
comunicações durante o mês de maio se às
vezes numa hora ouvimos aquela frase do
estado sistema é o caos
outro dos exemplos
tanto a nível da segurança ambiental
como movimentar navios de cruzeiros em
média levando cada 113 mil pessoas aqui
há uns 40 ou mais por dia um desses
navios punho equivalente a 11 milhões de
carros e por dois por semana o
equivalente a 10 filhos de natação cheia
de esgoto e para onde vai
de onde vem o país por acaso é a
proteína mais consumida em portugal este
ano apenas alguns dos muitos exemplos
que eu poderia apresentar sobre a
segurança marítima que é essencial num
país com pontua
para com isso quero apenas passar esta
forma de poder de um país muito
simplificada o poder é igual a
capacidade vezes a vontade ea capacidade
nós podemos fazer por ter faltado
vontade e essa vontade tem que ser uma
vontade de todos à vontade nacional
caso contrário informa a 0 e
entregaremos o nosso maior ativo outro
que esperam que ela continua lúcida e
perderemos nosso mar poderemos os nossos
cursos e vemos à nossa segurança
nacional afetada
espero que nunca mais coisas em portugal
da mesma forma como foi apresentado a
mim como pequeno com pobre e com prefere
e mentira
muito obrigado